hey guys how's it going so the 10.1 iOS
update came out today
which included the thing that everybody
had been waiting for since they
announced this feature is the portrait
mode in your camera software so
basically this is what it looks like
when you're just ready to take a normal
photo you switch to portrait it really
zooms in and when I first launched this
after updating it gave me this little
notice that said just letting you know
this is still beta but here you go feel
free to try it out let me just tap on
this Dasani bottle and it makes
everything in the background blurry so
I'm going to take a shot and when I take
this photo this without the depth
feature this is with without what this
is not a very good demonstration let me
see if I can take a better photo I'll
take a picture of the web PM that I'm
using so move further away it says
further away keep go Kay that's also not
a good representation ah so I already
took some pictures outside so I'd like
to show you those so this is a nice
little photo here let's zoom in and see
what we got going on setting instead of
showing these to you on my phone I'm
going to open them up in Photoshop so
here's the shots you can zoom in here
take a little peek see what we can see
this is with the depth effect on this is
without do you like it more do you like
it less I feel like this isn't a good
subject to really test this on because I
feel like it really is made for
something that is one object it's a lot
more forward than everything else
because I feel like it got a little bit
confused as like I don't really sure
what you're trying to keep in focus or
what's happening here here's with
portrait on with portrait off Wow
there's a huge difference in this one
look it got a little confused with this
little thing right there
[Music]
it's like are you a part of this are you
a part of this flower should I blur you
should I not should I stay should I go
okay we've got Maddie without the
portrait effect with the portrait effect
so let's really zoom in over here and
just take a look at this difference with
it without with it without take note of
these little stray hairs over here just
blurred them out like they ain't no
thing this is a pretty ugly photo but I
was just trying to find different
colored things in different scenarios so
it looks like right here we get a little
trouble with without with without also
notice right here it blurred that out
like what do you think it's just I think
it got confused and thought it was still
a part of this background hmm
so this was a difficult one because I
don't think it knew what was going on
okay it's like what are you focusing on
what you want me to focus on I'm not
even sure what I wanted to focus on I
just picked up the camera and took a
picture so this one's interesting
because it didn't really do that much
but you can see that it was trying to
find the line of what I wanted to be
blurred and it sort of did but it looks
like it had a little trouble here with
Maddie's little fur so this is with the
depth effect without with this out so I
think out of most of the ones that I
have besides another picture of Maddie
that I have coming up I think this is
probably one of my favorite examples it
did a pretty good job I think it looks
good looks really great so I think this
is probably one of my favorites that I
took besides the previous one that I
just showed you because I did a really
good job of blurring out all that
background Plus just enough of his
little body to make it look like a
really cool shot so I'm definitely
pretty into this one oh he was him
stretch in stretch it out bud stretch it
out well guys that is the portrait mode
I wonder
I don't know if I can even take a
picture of myself because it's probably
tell me to move it further away so let's
see what happens
Oh God it Susan so much I mean it would
basically be like you using like a 50
millimeter lens or something and trying
to like get a shot it did do a really
good job of blowing out that background
but I definitely don't think this is
something that I'll be using for my
profile picture or should i sorry I
didn't feel like putting makeup on I did
brush my hair for you today so that's a
start
let me know what you guys think of the
new portrait mode in iOS 10 and if you
guys haven't got my stickers yet please
check them out I just need stickers calm
I have about 30,000 iMessages from you
guys on my iPad so that has been
extremely overwhelming but it's been
really cool to try to respond to as many
as I can
I've had some great conversations with a
bunch of you guys and it is actually it
means so much more than you guys think
to be able to really get a chance to
talk to you guys because I don't go to
VidCon this year and for me that's
usually my way to sort of recharge and
just remember why I make videos it's for
you guys it's to get to talk to you and
I didn't have that this year so this has
been kind of cool to just FaceTime and
be able to talk to you one-on-one where
even at VidCon I don't really get that
opportunity because you guys get like
two seconds with your favorite creator
and then you're gone and even a book
tour I didn't get a chance to really
talk to you guys so this has been really
cool and it's been a lot of fun and I
hope that you guys have been enjoying
the stickers I've been enjoying chatting
with you and playing with all of the fun
things that I can stick them on and I
keep sending Jenna pictures of Maddie
but putting stickers of Maddie's face
over tappable like that's pretty much to
me the coolest thing ever all right let
me go I think I might actually update my
computer to Sierra today very excited
I'm also gonna set up my PS VR and I
think I'm gonna start playing overwatch
and then I'm gonna also play Gears I've
had a lot of plans for today it's
already three o'clock and I need to edit
this video so with that being said I'm
gonna go I love you I'll see you guys in
the next video peace so if you have no
idea what I'm talking about I just
posted a video where I talked about
launching my first-ever
sticker pack on iMessage give iOS 10 you
can download them
I just need stickers calm is the link
that will take you directly to it you
can click in the description also if you
don't feel like typing but I said that I
was going to FaceTime some of you guys
and also highlight some of the messages
that I have received and